let's move on seeking a game and yeah
it's taking us longer to find
five-minute games at this level
i've decided that we're going to go
approximately until 2500
because i think yeah srp thank you van
hargraves
okay oh we already play this guy uh so
let's go e4
[Music]
and he plays the karaoke now against the
karaoke
there's many good lines but one
very let's say pure line that i like to
showcase
is the two knights we just developed
both of our knights
and he goes bishop g4 brandon thank you
for the sub now against bishop g4 the
theoretical continuation
is to first play h3 okay he takes on f3
and we get the two bishops now
how should we position our pieces well
what do you guys think we should do here
yeah we have several possibilities here
um one possibility is to fianchetto the
bishop so we can
actually either play it with d3 or d4
so think of it this way if you play d3
that obstructs the diagonal for the
bishop so then we're gonna have to feed
and get of the bishop
or the move that i like to play is d4
that's simple
and it's uh it's an old-school move
now what should we take with and now
it's time for us to
experiment a little bit so taking with
the queen protects the pawn
but if we were to play in tall like
fashion we would take with the knight
we're going to play this in in my style
this is not entirely sound but why are
we sacrificing
upon because we have a lead in
development and we have the two bishops
and
this combination of factors to me
particularly in a blitz game
gives quite a bit of compensation also
his queen is stuck in the middle
where it can be assailed by by certain
pieces we can develop a tempo
that doesn't mean you immediately should
i think that black can neutralize my
initiative with accurate play
but to play accurately here is certainly
not easy at all and
this is again the judgment call that i'm
making
now having said a you have to say b as
the russian expression goes
and b means sacrificing another pawn
on b2 um if he takes that pawn his queen
gets even further into my territory and
i can use that okay so he
smartly dips this queen back but what
move is now possible i'll talk about
this uh
after the game i'll explain why queen
takes b2 is not that good for black
well now we can castle exactly look how
quickly we're developing
we have pressure down the d-file you
guys should just visually be able to see
the compensation
okay now one of the hardest things about
attacking in these positions is finding
ways to just keep twisting the knife
so one way to think about it is this
trades
in general are good for him so this
knight on e4 we only have one night left
uh which is why i want to keep it right
if he trades the knight we won't have
any like screwdriver pieces now we got
to think about where we want to put this
knight
we don't want to dip it back to c3 that
would be passive so can we find any more
active squares for the knight
and what i'm not going to tell you guys
right now is that
seeing this move and playing it hinges
on seeing a sacrifice because
you guys might look at this and say well
wait a second can't he chase the knight
away with h6
but in this position because all of our
pieces are nicely deployed you should
already be looking for sacrifices and
tactical ideas
that should not be a surprise to anyone
that these kinds of things already kind
of exist
now it's harder to actually find the
type of sacrifice but the fact that they
exist shouldn't be surprised to anybody
and h6 weakens the g6 where we'll get
into that after the game he didn't do it
he went knight e5 okay not a problem um
he actually helps us by
opening up the default we just need to
find a good square for the queen
and a good square would be somewhere out
of the way of the other pieces
and g3 comes to mind it's out of the way
it doesn't stumble
in front of the other pieces but at the
same time it does a lot controls the
diagonal and it buttresses the knight
which is an important piece
let's see if he takes the bishop we're
going to pre-move rook takes d3
um f4 would be a little bit more uh in
the face
right and it would walk into ideas like
95 potentially i'm not saying he would
have done that
but potentially a queen on f4 would also
interfere with the bishop's control of
the knight
so okay bishop d6 this is another reason
why we put the queen on g3
because now we can better deal with this
pin if we put the queen on f4 it would
be
harder for us to deal with the pen but
we got to be very very careful
a lot of people i'm sure are thinking
bishop f4 but
bishop f4 walks into knight to h5
that's an important detail to account
for so
instead of bishop f4 uh we are going to
play
f4 which is actually not like an ideal
move but at least our pawn now supports
the knight and we continue the
initiative in such positions you have to
you know you have to keep it going uh
sometimes
the attack won't work out immediately
but if you can keep the pressure on your
opponent if you can keep the foot on the
gas pedal
eventually something's going to give and
you got to believe that uh that's
why this is also kind of fun you're
you're living on the edge here i don't
think this is entirely objectively sound
but i do believe that my opponent's
eventually going to fold over
let's double the rooks yep bring the
rook into the game
knight d5 though is a very strong
defensive resource although i have a
response planned for it
okay so knight e5 let's think of this
move in terms of
its drawbacks the drawback of the
movement d5 is that it weakens the e4
square actually so we can dip our knight
back to e4
pressuring the bishop on d6 now you guys
might look at this and say well wait a
second
aren't you allowing bishop takes up f4
which is probably what he's going to
play
which leads to mass trades and the short
answer is yes i
am but i've calculated this line a
little bit further so let's see what
happens
we have to trade queens but believe it
or not in my opinion that's not as big
of a problem as it seems because
where can a rook now go
we can go rook to d7 i have to give
compliments to my opponent he's playing
this like a gm he's playing extremely
well
he's beating back my attack but now in
the end game we still have an initiative
we have a rook on the seventh we're two
pawns down we're going to win one of the
pawns back
he might also capture the pawn on g2 but
his knight might get in trouble
so um it's it's unclear we have
peace activity we still have an
initiative in the end game
but um you know this isn't necessarily
what i was looking for
but this is also what i talked about if
you keep on keeping on
uh your opponent is eventually going to
get tired and that's literally a thing
so what do we want to accomplish in a
position like this well ideally we want
both rooks to be on the seventh ring
that's called piggies on the seventh
well can we get that done can
can we get that done we can go c4 but
there's a problem with c4
he goes knight e3 i want you guys to
follow carefully he goes knight e3
um and then he can potentially come back
and take the pawn
so can we prepare the move c4
i know this looks lame
but um and there's several ways to do
but we're gonna go b3
and in addition to preparing rook d7 um
we're also building a potential pawn
train so even if we don't get our rook
to d7 and we do play c4
that pawn on c4 is independently of
anything else just going to be protected
and when you have these types of end
games where both knights are kind of
you know hacking away at each other's
pawns it's a very good idea to make sure
that you have as many puns
unprotected protected by other pawns as
possible i don't know if that makes
sense
but he doesn't actually prevent us from
getting the rook to d7 so
in the end game you can think of the
position as a function of two main
things peace activity and material
and people tend to underestimate the
role of peace activity people tend to
prioritize
counting up the material in the endgame
that's completely understandable because
it is important
but don't forget that peace activity can
be an absolute game changer
what do we do now how do we keep on
pressuring his position right we need to
get to his king
what's stopping us from getting to his
king well the immediate target is the f
pawn
so we can go knight g5 knight d6 would
have done the same thing
now it is true that he also um he also
is trying to get to our king but he
doesn't have enough
firepower to do that because his f8 rook
is passive
he's opened up the a file which is a
good thing but we are ready to take on
f7
and cut open an immediate artery to his
king
and then the tactics begin so
yeah i know we're 21 35
we're moving right along making progress
i i never call the knights horses so
rookie is a good move
and um well we got to think about
whether we want to trade rooks do we
want to trade rocks and if not
how do we avoid the trade of brooks
okay i gotta make a move guys i've got
no time so rook to c7 we do not want to
trade rooks because we want to keep the
piggies on the seventh
and we are actually threatening a really
cool tactical idea
does anybody see what white is
threatening here okay that's not a
problem
okay he actually defends so let's go g4
defending the pawn we're still
threatened i take c6 is correct and if
he takes he gets checkmated
i hope that he lets us do it now
the reason we shouldn't be afraid of
this is he just doesn't have enough
pieces in the attack
right he doesn't have enough to to
really do anything to my king and the
king has
this escape route should that be
necessary and actually i'm going to
exploit that escape route
watch my king now the king is actually
an asset not a weakness
the king actually kind of like that
goalkeeper which goes in to kick the
corner
is now an asset i'm threatening a
similar idea oh
and now a beautiful idea to win the game
somebody name it for me
bingo
actually i got to be a little careful
i think i cut this a little bit too
close
one sec
okay mate
that's where uh that that's where i come
in you know
don't try this at home um all right
don't try this at home
i got a little bit nervous there i think
i cut it too close when i was trying to
get people to find knight h6 okay
um so he plays the karo khan
now the karo khan was named after two
people
uh ilya khan i think and horatio cairo
so it's the karo dash con it wasn't one
person
and nor do i think they work together i
think cairo and khan
sort of independently developed the
system and uh kara khan was first played
in the year 1845.
caro in 1886 played it but he was only
like the tenther
oh khan played it before karo but before
either kara or khan played it there were
a couple of other players
who played it um some guy named weiss
played it
five times in 1883 r climbing thank you
so you know again it's one of those
things where
it's not that people didn't play this
before caro and con it's just that they
perhaps were the ones that played it
most consistently
and um you know probably they also wrote
some sort of treaties on
on on the kara khan so that's why this
came to be known as
as the karo khan and uh
this is most similar to the french it's
it's what i would call a
well it's basically you prepare d5
there's two moves where you prepare d5
and the other one is e6
it's a modern opening and it's very very
popular it's withstood the test of time
and it's a very good opening um
good night and i don't know yeah so i
decided to play the two knights right
developing both knights he
he goes for the bishop g4 system
his idea is to give up his bishop first
and then go e6 why didn't he go e6
immediately because then
the bishop would be stuck behind the
pawn chain this would be very passive
thank you zach miller priming
appreciate it all pawns and no hope is
right the french is not bad
so here i played d4 this is an old
school move i think nowadays
people tend to prefer g3 bishop g2 and
then d3
um so you basically you don't
claim as much of the center but the
center you do claim
is very well protected so the drawback
of d4 is precisely that you can play
dxc4 there was a famous fish or tall
game in this line
now queen takes e4 does protect the pawn
yeah the system is viable against the
french but it's not quite as good
and uh knight f6 yeah so if he goes
bishop h5
there is a very sharp line where
basically white
gets a big initiative by giving a check
and slamming the knight into e5 this
line is uh
considered to be very dangerous for
black although there's a lot of theory
here
i don't want to delve into that but
that's why he took on f3 thank you
dragon transformer another sub with the
prim
um but i decided to play knight txt4
so from a purely objective perspective
this is not a very sound
sacrifice although it's not bad um i
think it's not terribly unsound either
but um after knight f6 our opponent lets
us develop a tempo
and now we castle and here actually i'm
not sure about the move that i played
knight g5 i was kind of attracted to the
idea of sacking on e6
but i think that it would have been
better to be prophylactic so
our opponent wants to go 95 oh yeah
queen takes b2 sorry i forgot about that
so if queen takes b2 we simply castle
and i just want you guys to visually
compare the
development of white in the development
of black thank you moksha nirvana for
the 300
right white's got literally everything
developed black has virtually nothing
developed and
once i go rook b1 on rook takes b7 black
is just basically going to get
trackmated even if like manages to
castle short
it actually won't matter because of the
firepower that white has here really it
isn't about the pawns
all pawns are no hope as one wise man
said does that make sense
so again we can delve into the detail
here but you guys should really just
see this from a visual perspective above
all else
so he jumped dips back and here i
actually think i was invasion now
our opponent wants knight to e5 he wants
to trade off
this bishop on d3 which is sort of a
very important cog in the machine
could you guys propose a move whereby i
can
both prevent 95 but to do so while also
improving my position in
a tangible way three bucks from a zenith
sound bite thank you
well i'll i'll have to do that later
after the speed run concludes so bishop
c4 is possible queen g3 very good move
and uh as is yeah good job guys bishop
d4 also good because that would
centralize the bishop
okay that would centralize 547 if i look
at that
that's a sexy number if i may say so
myself so yeah that would have been good
i kind of missed this move to be honest
now if he played h6 this weakens the g6
square
and there's a very thematic idea
actually gary gaspara once fell into
this against deep blue
and just look at how bad the king badly
the king is placed
we can bring the rook into the game and
x-ray the king black can very easily get
checkmated in a position like this
now i know a lot of people are looking
at this and saying wait a second why not
bishop c5
and this is a piece of advice i have
everybody be very careful
very very careful not to underestimate
the amount of pieces that you are giving
away
in return for the queen okay this is
something i see all the time
like you'll people will find some crazy
sequence of
work i'm winning and then they'll give
up two rooks and three pieces and five
pawns for the queen
right there you can collect sufficient
material for the queen and this is a
case of that
you have a rook in two pieces for the
queen and white white's attack kind of
fizzles out
there's no need for this it's much
better to just accumulate prepare slowly
attack fast
rather than do something like that
okay um
well no i didn't have this idea here
first and foremost because actually
maybe i did
actually that's not so bad no but he can
move his queen away this is actually
funny because if i take c6
you can do this but the same thing
applies here black is a million pieces
for the queen
so this isn't that good
yeah so queen g3 instead bishop d6 is a
very good move
now if bishop f4 knight h5 forks the
bishop and the queen
leading to a lot of problems yeah and i
gotta attribute that to my coach lap
size
so we go f4 and actually here i think
there was a critical moment so queen c7
is good
and now knight d5 super annoying and
this is a very typical thing in the car
con that happens right
he gets this stronghold on d5 which
shuts down the d file i have to reopen
the default knight e4
gets the knight back to a relatively
civilized square and we attack g7 we
basically force the transition into the
end game
now if you take it on e3 first who can
tell me why this doesn't like win a lot
of material
what is the important detail here knight
takes d6 is correct
followed by queen takes c3 and white
wins a p so that's an important detail
now in the end game white just to
reiterate
the the sort of the fact that white is
down two pawns
is is compensated by the fact that y has
the rook on d7 i have control over the d
file
and uh his rooks are very very passive
now when you turn on the computer it
gives
a hefty advantage for black but i would
argue
i would have the audacity to argue that
the reality is uh
from a blitz perspective from a
practical perspective this is a
difficult position to play
for black and i think you guys saw that
manifest itself in the game it's very
hard
the computer knows exactly you know how
to wiggle his
its way out of things and computer is
never afraid of peace activity
the humans are and they should be so
knight t5 is already inaccurate
according to the computer which greedily
prefers b6 not an easy move to play
because basically you're supposed to
allow this to happen
and just trade one pair of rocks rook 88
you know it all seems very obvious it's
like my game against l shot
right uh when you look at the game with
a computer
you think you're an idiot really and
this persists all the way to the gm
level
so it's a little bit depressing to do
that take the computer suggestions of
the grain of salt no you're not an idiot
you're not dumb it's just that computers
are
so much better than humans ever will be
in my opinion
it's important to analyze with a
computer insofar as it reveals mistakes
but you should certainly not take it as
a sign that you suck or anything like
that because
you do suck and i suck and magna sucks
and we all suck in comparison to
computers
that doesn't mean we don't want to
improve okay and i didn't really follow
my own advice
because i hold myself to very high
standards
but you guys should not do that
to the same extent that i do it my
opinion the knight t5 rook takes b7
castles now c4
would meet with knight e3 right and i
didn't want to give away
a pawn for nothing even though we do get
a rook to d7 so
that's why we play b3 preparing the move
c4 and building up a punch chain
at this point already um he's in trouble
rook d7
getting the knight to g5 why are we not
worried that he opens up the afl because
he doesn't have the other rook and with
only a rook and a knight
he can't create any chances now
knight takes c6 here how does this idea
work so if ftxd6 this is a concept
everybody should commit to memory
this mating idea is very common when
you've got piggies on the seven thank
you joshua all day
but the problem is what what does black
have in this position
yeah i could have considered that goran
zarge that would have led to some really
interesting complications
but he first takes g2 he defends the
pawn preemptively now he takes e6 that
is why i had to play g4
now we have to escape the potential for
discovery very patiently
wiggling the king to c5 now i can't take
on e6 but i can take on f7
and knight takes h6 check is exactly the
same concept
if he takes check check
and checkmate at this point we got into
some time pressure but
the win is very straightforward g5 to
defend the knight
win one pawn get the night over well i
could have taken the rook here but
it didn't matter i'm completely winning
at this point winning the rook
and i actually managed to preserve
reasonably good technique despite the
time pressure so
i was um i was quite happy with that but
uh you guys can see how quickly black's
position deteriorated in that end game
so what's the lesson from this the
lesson is you shouldn't automatically
rule out an endgame
even when you're down a bunch of pawns
right
uh because there are certain end games
where the piece activity
disparity is so vast that you might be
even down three pawns i can show you
examples you might be down a whole piece
and yet the and that's rare admittedly
but the disparity in peace activity is
sometimes equally important if not more
important than the material account
thank you not danny19
loving the uh the hype almost at 3 500
amazing stuff guys
yeah so rook behave in this position
well
then yeah maybe rook b would have been
actually not so bad but but we would
have got knight c5 and he has a hard
time defending these pawns
um and any questions any other questions
about this game
i think it was a complicated game but
hopefully i made everything relatively
clear
okay looks like we're pretty clear let's
play one more
you guys are ready for the next one and
oh
damos 1289 gifting five thank you my
friend
damos 1289 raising that hype with the
subs and let's play king's indian let's
go back to uh
my home base let's play king's indian
and he plays what's called the tory
attack the tory attack is a similar
opening to the london
system where black white develops to f4
and in the tory white simply develops
the g5
it's similar in spirit to the london
white does many of the same things
and logically black also does many of
the same things so
the great thing about the king's indian
the reason i recommend it to a lot of
players is that
you don't really have to modify your set
of moves
depending on what your opponent does uh
which is not to say it's not theoretical
but if you understand the ideas you can
react
reasonably to most things your opponent
can throw at you theo 25k
so what do the king's indian moves
basically look like here
what should we do now should we go d5
that would be more grunfeld style
not really if we want to preserve the
king's india any ness of it we should go
d6
and as i've explained previously in the
king's indian black has two main pawn
breaks c5
and e5 in the toure one of the ideas
is that white discourages e5 because he
puts the bishop on g5 preemptively does
it make sense guys that
white's going to have this nasty pin if
we go e5 so let's not fall into his
plan let's actually punt on this let's
table that conversation
by finishing our development first let's
look at this bishop for a second where
can it go
thank you archdruid and tenacious where
can this bishop go what would be a nice
juicy
weighty square for that bishop not g4 if
it goes to g4 guys he's just going to
take it away with h3
we're actually going to fiance in the
interest of time i'm going to make the
move we're going to fee and get of the
bishop
and we're going to talk about this
moment after i don't expect people to
just like know this stuff
uh now he wants to go a5 so we're going
to go a5
ourselves to prevent him from doing that
and now we're going to develop the
knight d7 we don't want to develop it to
c6 to obstruct the bishop now he builds
up a little battery here
can we blunt that battery for now
yeah he's six now wait a second i hear
you guys saying but doesn't that open up
the pin
well it does but guess what that's not
such a dangerous spin we can get rid of
it by playing g5 if we need to
i'm not saying we'll do that immediately
we can also get rid of the pin by moving
the queen
and here i'm going to show you guys a
really really cool idea
really whoa big for raid 127 we were
doing holy smokes we had a dono
chest jacob 100 bucks wow
are you kidding me and we are going to
go g5 let's get rid of the pen thinking
bigfoot for the raid i can't even keep
up with this
this is unbelievable levels of support
guys what a raid what a dono
welcome guys we're doing the speedrun
thank you so much jess jacob
how do we follow this move up how do we
get rid of this bishop yeah that h5 is
the typical follow-up
i'll show you guys the cool idea
afterwards it didn't quite work here but
i'll show you guys afterwards
this is amazing guys i i not the way i
played today i didn't earn it but i
really appreciate it nonetheless now
what is going to be our
strategy our strategy here broadly
speaking
is going to be to accumulate pieces on
the king's side that's all we're going
to do let's get our queen to f6
slowly but surely we're going to
accumulate pieces on the queen side
and eventually you know
at some point in the very distant future
we're going to try to play 5. now the
situation has changed he goes e5
he doesn't actually win upon why doesn't
he win upon what can we do here
what very important intermediate move
does black
have to play because if we take on d6 we
actually drop the pawn
but we take the bishop that's partially
why we played knight h5 we take the
bishop
and now we take the pawn we're in pretty
decent shape here he's actually playing
super super well this guy um our
position is a little bit precarious
black has some weaknesses but we also
have the two bishops
let's get the knight over to f6 again
our plan is to accumulate pieces on the
king's side and eventually we're going
to launch into an attack
now one thing i'm noticing here is that
when he took on g3 with the pawn he
weakened that h file so
a potential idea is to go queen h5
knight g4 we don't have to do that
immediately but in fact
we actually can let's get the knight to
g4 i don't see a downside to this move
uh notice that when i play queen h5 i'm
not going to be threatening queen h2 but
his knight on f3 is going to be charged
with a very heavy load
and we're going to start looking for
some overloading tactics to try to get
that knight out of f3 also don't forget
about the bishop
that's why we fianchetto did it's
occupying a really big diagonal
literally holy smokes
30 on top of the 100 by chess jacob
we got 30 subs ladies and gentlemen that
propels us over 5500 subs
my land girl this is
crazy let's trade the knights absolutely
unbelievable thank you so much chess
jacob
this is incredible now we're gonna start
pushing the puns we're gonna try to tear
apart the defenses
around his king amazing thank you so
much
50 over 5500 now we're gonna go rook ba
why did we play this move
why did we play rook b8 and in the
interest of time i'm accelerating my
pace a little bit here
but i want somebody on top of that
flowner with a sub
we're going to shut him down with d5
somebody needs to give that man a sub
thank you chess jake i really appreciate
it man
we needed to protect v6 and we did that
indirectly
he's not a sub unacceptable
okay now what happens if he takes the
pawn on v6 this is where things get a
little bit gnarly and complicated
but i'll walk you guys through this
properly after the game the bottom line
is we're still trying to attack on the
king side and we're going to do that
by pushing the pawns and trying to open
up
trying to deal with tommy gifting to
chess jacob
trying to deal with his own pawns on the
king's side that's going to let us
pave the way for our pieces to come in
and start attacking so
how specifically should we go about
ripping this apart
this is an idea that i mentioned
previously let's not forget about it
what was our initial idea
i said that we'd do this eventually yeah
f5 f4
let's go now this is not that simple
right because we're weakening the e6
square
and that's a pretty serious weakness
that we've created it's right in the
crosshairs of his rook
so a good move for him would be bishop
d3 but i've judged
that i'm going to you know kind of like
an nfl blitz i'm going to blitz this
pawn up the board
and i've made the judgment call that
he's not going to have the time
to exploit the newly created weakness of
e6 i don't know if that makes sense
that's basically my logic because i'm
right on the doorstep of playing f4 and
when i do
i just feel like his king is not going
to survive very much longer
and i can always defend e6 worst comes
to wars
by dipping my bishop to c8 bat you know
bad bishops defend good pawns
he plays that for himself now how should
we should we take on passant
i'll give you guys a hint we actually
don't have to
he closed one freeway he closed one
freeway
but let's open the other freeway we can
take the other freeway we can take the h
file
here's the thing in a certain sense
follow my logic here
it's actually a good thing it's actually
a good thing
that he locked up the entire center
because this lets
us fully focus on the other side of the
board
now we can divert all of our resources
to the h-file
including the bishop to h6 the queen to
h4 and we don't have to worry about
anything happening in the center at
least for the time being
and i've actually just missed this move
um
i actually completely forgot i could do
that that's okay you've got to be able
to recover in these situations what do
we do
you know what we do nothing we just
let's first go queen h6
and here's what i've come up with here's
what i've come up with
what we're okay well i've come up with
winning his knight he should have
defended that pun
this is the point i always make though
when you put your opponent under
pressure
throughout the game he gets tired and it
that increases the probability of a
blunder
i'll explain what i would have done if
he had defended the plan i actually did
miss king f2
to be completely fair we have won a
knight let's not relax too soon because
he can finally take his six
it's kind of funny it's fitting that he
has finally taken the pun
but he's done it at the cost of a night
and his entire king side has collapsed
okay um thank you again chess jacob for
the 30 gifted we've had so many bombs
today so much support so many donors
and i really really appreciate it guys
we are on the path to 6
000 subs i cannot freaking believe it
now i'm looking at this bishop and i'm
saying man
i really want this bishop on e3 that
square would be really sexy
can we get that bishop to e3 we can't
play bishop h6 right
wait a minute can we get the bishop to
h6 we can you ask the sam shanklin
question what happens if i do it anyway
okay we're definitely gonna trade queens
to simplify
right what happens if i do it anyway if
he had taken that rook we would have had
a fork with queen e3 i'll show this
after the game
um and and and that really is something
i
advocate for players of all levels uh
gm's and
you know all of my students receive a
healthy dose of this
suggestion basically at all times now
again we've got some time pressure so we
just need to move the bishop away
dip the kink to h8 so that we can if
necessary block it with rook h7 let's
bring our bishop back he's probably
going to give us a check
we're gonna go here i actually believe
it or not i did blunder
that's the funny thing i blundered
because uh i have to go rook g7 i forgot
this bishop was hanging
okay and so did he but uh he's gonna
lose on time sorry about that in the end
nobody's perfect however so another very
rich game these people are playing very
very well
so he played the tory attack the tory
attack was named after carlos
torre mexican one of the strongest
players to come out of mexico
uh i think he basically flourished in
the first half of the 20th century
and the first guy to play this was a guy
named
coleman in 1923. eugene coleman
who lost against richard retti
and remember i mentioned retsy retsy was
one of the hyper modernists he was one
of those guys in the 1920s
who basically said um you don't have to
play
uh he was a check check player he said
you don't have to control the center of
your puns
it ain't a surprise to anybody that um
that it shouldn't be a surprise to me
that that reti was playing the king's
indian in the 1920s when it was still
unpopular
but then um tori himself
did he actually ever play the tory in
this move order let me see
um it's one of those things you know
yeah tori did play it oh but i think
it's named after yokanyotory
okay this is really really interesting
guys
so tori refers to two players carlos
torre from mexico
and much more recently eugenio torre
eugenio cherry from the philippines one
of the strongest grandmasters in the
philippines
he's still alive he's in his 60s i never
knew this but i think the tory attack is
named after eugeniotori from the
philippines
not carlos torre um it was around before
eugenio but i think he's
i see he's played it like over 20 times
so i actually think it's named after him
and not carla story pretty interesting
that's a pretty recent thing but anyway
nice little piece of trivia bishop g5
similar to the london
castles bishop c4 so normally in the
tory white develops the bishop i think
to d3 or e2 bishop c4 is a slightly
unusual way of developing
and d5 would be possible here with tempo
but we wanted to keep the king's
indian-ness of the line
so b6 to deploy the bishop now why is
bishop g4 not effective who can explain
this to me
succinctly why is bishop g4 why i mean
usually we develop our bishop that why
all of a sudden
did i reject this natural developing
square exactly he goes h3 and the
problem guys
when we fianchetto our bishop this
bishop that we put on this diagonal
doesn't have a retreat square
so we allow him to trap the bishop and
we would either have to take on f3
doesn't make sense or bring the bishop
back thank you super scrub
so for that reason we fianchetto
division a45
and e6 to blunt the battery now h6 and
now i decided to just get rid of the pin
g5 not h1
now a little bit of decision logic how
did i decide
that it was worth weakening the king
side in this way like
isn't this very weakening to go g5
um well as i've explained previously the
main
aspect of the logic that i use is to
figure out okay does white have the
capacity
in the next couple of moves to exploit
the weakness of the king side
and what do i notice his queen is on the
queen side his bishop's on the queen
side
most of his pieces are in some way
clustered on the queen side which means
it's going to take him a long time
to get them back to the king side and in
that time i'm going to bring the beef
to the king side which i do on the next
move does that make sense
so here e takes d6 we take on g3 and now
we begin what was the cool idea so
basically i had this idea
and i will show you guys a example in a
similar position of where i applied this
idea in one of my games
it's my favorite opening it's you know
people ask me about my favorite opening
sometimes i roll my eyes with that
question but if i had to choose it would
definitely be the king's indian
so you guys can see this game the story
behind this game this is uh
in this tournament in london in december
it's very cold i got very very sick in
this tournament so i remember
i had the flu and at the time this game
was played i started getting that sore
throat you guys know
when you get sick i always it always
starts with a sore throat for me
and the pain was getting excruciating i
mean i was playing
and i was in agonizing pain i couldn't
swallow
um but in this game i was feeling that
fever rising up
and i was basically playing a whole game
delirious but nonetheless
i managed to apply the idea this is only
round one it says round two but
basically this is round one
and then i actually did okay in the
tournament given how sick i was
but uh this game i actually played quite
well
and then i ran to my room and took all
the medicine i could find but it didn't
help my throat
okay so this idea
is involves improving the queen i'll
give you guys a hint
you build a battery like the ultimate
end goal of this idea which is two moves
long is to build a battery now what kind
of battery
yeah i was freezing and then i went all
around these indian restaurants trying
to get the spiciest curry to knock it
out
bingo rook a2 quinn a1 very typical idea
by the way
and ultimately the idea is to build this
battery along the long diagonal
which can be used to pressure it now
ultimately it wasn't that simple i got
my queen back
you know i re-maneuvered my pieces but
look at how now the queen and the bishop
are very nicely supervising the queen
side pressure i actually ended up
playing a very very nice game here
and um that's the bottom line idea
yeah i've been on the whole time
but um i've been doing i went away for a
little bit
and um i will be playing blitz as well
and feeling more energetic now so
that was the bottom line uh but why
didn't i do this here the reason i
didn't do this here
coming back to our speed run scene
is that um i was a little bit worried
of him essentially rushing
his pawn down the board or he could go
bishop d3 and i was not
quite able to detect how i would apply
more pressure on the pawn
but this this this has its time in place
but i thought this idea was quite a bit
sexier
so now the next stage of the game begins
where we accumulate
pieces on the king side and we use our
pawns as battering rams
to shatter the defenses around his king
how do i know that i need to attack here
well i've already gotten my queen here
and i know that this bishop has a
tremendous amount of potential energy
tremendous amount of potential energy
and i know that if i'm able to open up
files
i'll be able to use these pieces to my
advantage so h5
rook a b8 now this move indirect defense
of the pawn what happens if queen takes
b6 what specifically
does black do in this position
well we got something five bucks not
danny 19 thank you my friend
bishop takes g2 would be a very good
move killing two birds with one stone
winning a pawn
and removing one of the defenders around
his king take the juicer
now we go d5 we keep the bishop on v7
now doesn't this close down the bishop
it does but i
judged that ultimately the bishop would
be able to reroute via c8
or via a6 i wasn't too worried about
this
so g4 here comes the f-plan
so let's um talk about my mistake now
basically
this move queen h4 was very hasty this
move was very hasty
i just forgot that he can bring his king
to f2 now what should we have done in
this position instead
um i think that i should have re redid
my move order here it's actually not
that simple this idea of king f2
is quite an annoying one i actually
think that i rushed i didn't practice
what i preached
now if you guys know if you got yeah
bishop h6 preemptively
this is a very savvy move because if he
plays king f2
now we take on g3 and he can't take with
the knight yes he has to take with the
king
and at this point black has a lot of
different tactical ideas we can consider
a bishop sack
but whatever we do this this king is oh
oh my god i just saw something i use the
word sexy
and i mean it here king g7 creates a
beautiful threat
i think this works black to play and win
black to play and win
okay let's let people let's let people
think the non-title players
queen h4 and bishop f4
there's no defense i think
against rook h8 checkmate and if knight
bishop f5 rock f6 though
check you sack one rook and you
checkmate with the other one
that's actually quite a beautiful idea
i'm not sure this actually works but um
it's uh oh bishop takes f5 actually
more no this wins this actually wins
wow amazing so that would have been
quite the nice
end to the game and i just checked with
the engine but he ended up blundering
the pawn
he should have gone queen d2 defending
and he actually gets the rook to h1 and
actually white is more or less fine here
i was going to reroute my bishop and put
it on h4
you get kind of some tension down the h5
i'm not sure who benefits from it so
this would have been quite complicated i
should not have allowed it
but all's well that ends well he
blunders the pawn and the piece comes
with it and that's how we won
ultimately our attack succeeded and we
were able to stave off his central
pressure
and and that basically uh you know
that is basically that
[Music]